bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de rappel dos je suis
ravie de vous retrouver au Parlement
européen à Strasbourg dans cette
émission je vous emmène à grande j en
Sicile un petit village frappé par la
désertification et par l'exode rural
alors pour réhabiliter ces maisons son
maire a décidé de les brader à 1 euro
vendre le patrimoine pour éviter qu'il
ne tombe en ruine et pour remplir les
caisses un phénomène qui qui touche pas
dans toute l'Italie nous y reviendrons
quel budget pour 2015 c'est l'épineuse
question qu'elle est députée européens
ont dû répondre et ces gens Arthuis le
tout nouveau président de la commission
des budgets qui nous en parle mais
d'abord l'actualité Jean-Claude Juncker
et sa commission sont-ils un renouveau
dans cette union européenne c'est Simon
barbarie qui pose la question
on prend les mêmes et on recommence un a
priori qui sonne comme un défi pour
Jean-Claude Juncker car comment
représenter le renouveau de l'Union
européenne quand on a passé 20 ans à la
tête du Luxembourg et 8 ans à celle de
l'euro groupe du routard de la politique
luxembourgeoise et européenne sa
commission est à son image des anciens
ministres des anciens chefs de
gouvernement et des anciens commissaires
un collège qui risque de ne pas arranger
les accusations de déficit démocratique
de l'Union avec une abstention de 57%
lors des dernières élections européennes
et l'arrivée de près de 140 députés
europhobe au Parlement le plus dur reste
à faire et les défis nombreux son neurom
menacé d'une nouvelle crise opacité
autour des négociations du traité
transatlantique de libre-échange
relation toujours aussi tendues avec la
Russie depuis la crise ukrainienne
l'Europe est sous pression et première
réponse de Jean-Claude Juncker l'annonce
d'un plan d'investissement de 300
milliards d'euros pour doper la
croissance et l'emploi alors que le
budget européen n'a jamais été aussi Ré
duit mais avant il y aura un premier
test celui de l'examen des budgets
français et italiens en déficit donc pas
vraiment en phase avec l'orthodoxie
budgétaire de la zone euro sans oublier
les objectifs à fixer contre le
réchauffement climatique à l'horizon
2030 alors cette nouvelle commission
Juncker peut-elle changer l'Europe
cette nouvelle Commission peut-elle
changer l'Europe c'est la grande
question qu'on va poser à Edouard Martin
bonjour merci d'être avec nous Édouard
vous présente plus vous êtes un petit
peu la prise de guerre du Parti
socialiste lors de ces dernières
élections
Édouard Martin vous étiez dans
l'émission clé vous avez voté contre
l'investiture de cette commission
Juncker pourquoi ne pas avoir été
finalement à la Gauche Unitaire
européenne ou chez les Verts plutôt que
chez les socialistes si c'était pour
voter contre je suis effectivement
peut-être une prise de guerre de
pâtissierisme je suis un représentant de
la société civile égyptien
donc j'ai pas envie d'être entre
guillemets prisonnier de telle ou tel
corps mais ceci étant dit moi je la joue
collective aussi et dans la mesure du
possible j'essaie d'être en phase avec
mon groupe parlementaire néanmoins sur
cette affaire là et d'ailleurs c'était
le sujet la fin de votre sujet c'est les
300 milliards aujourd'hui c'est à peu le
monstre du Loch Ness tout le monde en
parle mais personne ne voit la couleur
pour être clair Jean-Claude Juncker lors
de son discours d'investiture en juillet
dernier à va annoncé un plan de 300
milliards d'investissement exactement
l'Union européenne pour relancer
l'économie pour relancer la croissance
et il a été donc attaqué par plusieurs
des groupes de ce Parlement sur d'où
viennent ces 300 milliards d'où est-ce
que cela va sortir il a pas répondu à la
question selon vous pas du tout parce
qu'il y a le discours de Juncker qui est
plutôt intéressant je veux dire pour
justement cette réorientation de
l'Europe mais après elle a la réalité la
réalité pour nous ça a été l'audition
des commissaires et lorsqu'on pose la
question à monsieur catinen qui va être
lui un peu le monsieur budget il nous
dit il ne s'agit pas de 300 milliards
d'argent frais il s'agit de 300
milliards d'économies que les États
devront faire donc la conclusion que
j'en tire moi ça veut dire encore plus
d'austérité et yunker là encore dit tout
à l'heure ça a démontré que l'austérité
n'apporte aucune croissance et ça ne
crée pas d'emploi donc mais il n'a pas
su encore nous répondre l'origine de ces
300 milliards donc moi j'ai pas raison
de signer un chèque en blanc les
discours ça va 5 minutes mais non on
veut des heures
Martin mais non mais s'abstenir ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que
j'ai fait effectivement après valoir
entre guillemets j'étais prêt à lui
faire confiance mais j'attendais un peu
plus de détails justement au moment de
la désignation de la commission pour
connaître le le périmètre de ces 300
milliards or on arrive au moment 3 mois
après au moment où il faille où il faut
voter la Commission et je j'ai toujours
les mêmes doutes sur l'origine de ces
300 milliards donc le nom c'est dire
voilà vous n'avez pas levé mes doutes
moi je ne vous ferai pas un chèque en
blanc donc je je vous montre carrément
contre contre mais je n'aspire qu'à une
chose très honnêtement que yunker me
démontre que j'ai eu tort de voter
contre sa commission et et je serai le
premier heureux parce que aujourd'hui il
s'agit pas d'une petite Giger est-ce
qu'on est pro Junker contre une coeur il
s'agit de comment l'Europe apporte enfin
des réponses à la crise que nous vivons
c'est ça le le fond du débat justement
je voudrais qu'on réécoute un moment du
discours de Jean-Claude Juncker ou
celui-ci s'adresse un petit peu à Berlin
on écoute
nous allons respecter la discipline
budgétaire c'est indispensable mais nous
allons faire preuve de flexibilité c'est
indispensable les réformes structurelles
doivent arriver sans réforme
structurelle pour modifier l'économie
européenne et le marché de l'emploi en
Europe il n'y aura pas de croissance il
n'y aura pas de flexibilité
alors expliquez-moi un petit peu Édouard
Martin vous venez de dire exactement la
même chose que ce qu'il vient de dire à
l'instant alors pourquoi voter contre
une fois de plus
rassurer Madame Merkel et c'est ça c'est
là où le bât blesse et on connaît le
discours de ma mère j'ai si j'avais pu
échanger avec lui de tête en tête-à-tête
juridique on aurait pu économiser
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'argent on
aurait pu éviter l'audition des 27
commissaires il n'avait juste qu'à
auditionné Madame Merkel et qui nous
donne elle le la de la rotation
européenne sauf que l'Europe c'est
l'Europe des 28 c'est pas l'Europe de
Madame Merkel et d'ailleurs l'Allemagne
commence à se rendre compte que cette
politique d'austérité est aussi nuisible
pour l'Allemagne
sont mauvaises sur les prochaines
semaines dire au pays du Sud qui qui
sont dans une crise mais
extraordinairement dramatique ou de
toute façon ce que la troïque elle
aurait imposé en bois bien que c'est des
pays qui sont fausses de plus en plus ça
va nuire à l'ensemble de la collectivité
il faut de la solidarité et je pense que
les 300 milliards il faut que ce soit
l'argent frais relancer les
investissements publics alors on voit
justement que cette commission et on le
voit sur les images qui défilent
actuellement a été investi donc au
Parlement européen elle va entrer en
action à partir du 1er novembre
finalement positif c'est que on dit
adieu baruso il faut le souligner
finalement c'est plutôt un point positif
vous-même comment est-ce que vous vous
inscrivez Edouard Martin dans le cadre
de cette délégation socialiste vous
n'êtes donc pas adhérents aux parties
socialiste vous n'êtes pas dans les dans
la ligne du parti forcément mais je sais
que vous n'êtes pas tout seul mais en
gros je pense que vous pouvez comment
est-ce que vous pouvez imaginer finir un
mandat alors que vous prenez quand même
déjà vos aises si je puis dire avec la
ligne du parti
quand le Parti socialiste est venu me
chercher entre guillemets et appris
quelques semaines de réflexion de débats
j'ai fini par dire oui j'ai pris
personne par par
à contre-pied j'ai dit que je voulais
garder cette liberté de penser par
moi-même alors j'ai peut-être tort
encore une fois je ne demande qu'une
chose c'est que yunker me démontre que
j'ai eu tort de votre trait contre cette
commission là mais je m'inscris pas dans
un schéma destructeur moi j'ai
simplement envie effectivement que cette
Europe enfin soit l'Europe des citoyens
donc les 300 milliards ce sont que le
début de cette parce que ça ne suffira
pas à 300 milliards et à partir de ce
moment-là moi je suis tout à fait prêt à
dire dans les semaines dans les mois qui
viennent dire voilà Monsieur Juncker
prend la bonne orientation et j'adhère à
cette politique là parce que enfin elle
répond aux aspirations des citoyens je
ne veux pas prisonnier d'addock moi quel
qu'il soit j'ai voté contre mon ami
conscience parce que j'estime encore une
fois que les 300 milliards sont la
grande inconnue du projet de relance de
l'Europe bon alors moi ce que je vous
propose du coup c'est que Édouard Martin
on vous réinvite dans quelques mois et
que vous soyez en capacité ou pas de
nous dire si Jean-Claude Juncker vous
fait confiance merci d'avoir été avec
nous bon nous on continue la grande
question de ces derniers jours c'était
effectivement la question du budget et
on vient d'en parler avec les 300
milliards et je reçois Jean artuy pour
évoquer cette question à tout de suite
bonjour vous êtes le tout nouveau
président de la commission des budgets
vous succédez à Alain lamasfour qui est
chef de la délégation désormais du
groupe PPE français le budget européen
sur l'année 2015 vient d'être votée
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait de ce que
vous avez réussi à obtenir de la part
des députés européens il est voté par le
Parlement mais pour qu'il soit
exécutoire il faut un accord entre le
Conseil et le Parlement ce sont les deux
branches de l'autorité budgétaire et
donc va s'engager maintenant une
tentative de conciliation entre le
Conseil représentant les chefs d'État de
gouvernement et le Parlement et là
l'épreuve va commencer parce que nous
avons une vraie difficulté qui est liée
à l'apparition d'une dette la commission
accumule des factures qu'elle ne sait
pas payer la dette la dette était de 5
milliards en 2010 elle est passée à 11
milliards en 2011 à 16 milliards en 2012
à 23 milliards en 2013 et aujourd'hui
elle est entre 25 et 30 milliards ça
veut dire des associations en difficulté
pour la France par exemple au titre du
FSE
les associations des départements des
conseils généraux des conseils régionaux
pour la formation professionnelle il y
avait 350 milliards millions d'un pays à
la fin de l'année 2013 donc nous
essayons que cette situation ne peut pas
durer et la difficulté que nous allons
avoir dans cette conciliation entre le
Parlement le Conseil et on présence de
la commission c'est de rapprocher les
points de vue Jean-Claude Juncker a
annoncé un plan d'investissement global
de 300 milliards d'euros pour relancer
l'économie européenne est-ce que vous y
croyez Jean arthuile d'où peut venir cet
argent les 300 milliards c'est c'est
providaniel alors la question qui se
pose c'est de savoir d'où ils vont venir
je crois pas que ça puisse être financé
par un recyclage des crédits qui sont
dans dans le plan pluriel parce que tout
ça est très engagé crédit de cohésion
pour structurelle les marches de Madame
ne sont pas là on le voit bien c'est un
budget qui n'a pas de marge de manœuvre
et donc il va falloir mobiliser des
fonds qui ne sont pas des fonds publics
de doper la recherche l'innovation le
numérique c'est dire si je suis
impatient de connaître le dispositif
mais je sais que ça viendra avec Noël
autre serpent de mer qui agite la
question du budget européen depuis des
années c'est la question des
fonds produits sur le fait de mettre en
place par exemple une taxe carbone aux
frontières qui viendrait directement
abonder le budget européen bien sûr à
condition que ce ne soit pas un impôt
supplémentaire et un alourdissement des
prélèvements obligatoires je souhaite
que le Parlement européen
puisse être un parlement qui vote
l'impôt or on voit bien que le Parlement
européen lorsqu'il examine un projet de
budget n'a pas à sa disposition le
levier fiscal il n'y a pas d'impôts de
repère les seuls impôts sont les droits
de douane et les droits de douane
à condition de trouver un impôt qui soit
juste qui soit efficace le l'impôt fondé
sur la les côtes taxes en quelque sorte
aux frontières une taxe carbone donc
finalement vous êtes un petit peu sur la
ligne de Ségolène Royal je suis d'accord
pour que l'on puisse aux frontières
rétablir un équilibre et faire
disparaître
pourcentage compétitif qui n'a pas de
justification et seriez-vous d'accord
pour la mise en place d'une taxe sur les
transactions financières
c'est beau comme l'antique la taxe de
direction financière ça fait ça alimente
des discours qui enflamment les foules
mais il n'y a rien de plus délocalisant
qu'une transaction financière donc si
l'on veut faire un cadeau à la City de
Londres et il suffit d'instituer une
taxe sur les transactions financières
dans dans les autres pays l'Union
européenne il y a quelques pays
volontaires très bien c'est magnifique
mais je mets en garde car on risque
alors de s'en tenir pour éviter les
délocalisations à un impôt qui sera
symbolique et une fois encore on aura
fait de la gesticulation alors je crois
que nos concitoyens attendent une action
réelle effective qu'on arrête de leur
raconter des histoires de belles
histoires la France a présenté son
projet de budget à Bruxelles le 15
octobre dernier celle-ci doit rendre un
avis avant la fin octobre
vous en tant que président de cette
commission des budgets au Parlement
européen si vous en aviez la capacité
est-ce que vous valideriez ce projet de
budget français
puisque elle a demandé à plusieurs
reprises de pouvoir bénéficier de délai
pour assumer ses responsabilités et la
France de respecte pas ces engagements
or je vois poindre un débat qui met en
cause l'Europe l'austérité mais s'il n'y
avait pas l'Europe si la France avait le
franc pour monnaie et n'était pas dans
la solidarité européenne et bien la
France serait instantanément mise dans
l'obligation
d'équilibrer ses comptes faute de quoi
les emprunts seraient souscrits à des
taux d'intérêt extrêmement élevés et
nous serions dans la pire des situations
donc selon vous celle ne doit pas
valider le budget français
ce budget va être critiqué forcément
même le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques qui étaient instituées par le
président Hollande est ratifié par le
Parlement français même le conseil est
critique sur ce budget donc là encore on
est dans le déni de réalité les réformes
structurelles ne se font pas et
l'équilibre des finances publiques est
sans cesse reporter on fait de belles
annonces mais on est vraiment dans la
rhétorique et ça ne peut pas continuer
ainsi merci beaucoup Jean Arthur d'avoir
été notre invité nous on
continue sur les questions bud
gétaires à Gandji en Sicile c'est un
petit village qui est frappé par l'exode
rural depuis des dizaines d'années alors
le maire pour lutter contre les ruines a
décidé de vendre les maisons au prix
exceptionnelles de 1 euro mais c'est un
phénomène qui ne touche pas que la
Sicile mais toute l'Italie voir une
grande partie de l'Europe reportage de
Faustine Saint-Geniès
voici Ganji un village de montagne au
cœur de la Sicile avec ses églises ces
ruelles tortueuses c'est papy qui chante
et ses maisons à un euro
des maisons typiques des années 20
laissé à l'abandon en plein centre-ville
tes touristes Singapouriens sont venus
spécialement pour en visiter avec un
agent immobilier
ça c'était la pièce pour les animaux ici
vous avez la mangeoire au dessus vous
avez des chambres et au dernier étage de
la cuisine allez venez je vous fais
visiter
du réfrigérateur c'est naturellement
froid
les visiteurs sont très intéressés
malgré le coût de la rénovation au moins
60000 euros
mais une fois que ce sera fait ça sera
vraiment beau et qu'est-ce que vous
auriez à Singapour pour 60 000 euros
vous n'auriez pas une maison en tout cas
vous auriez une petite voiture si vous
avez de la chance
pour 1 euro symbolique c'est l'idée de
Giuseppe ferrarello le maire de ce
village de 7000 âme depuis les années 20
les conditions de vie et le manque de
travail on peut à peu vider Ganji de ses
habitants alors il y a 5 ans le maire a
lancé cette opération
les premières années on en a vendu
aucune ensuite en 2010 on a fait les
premières ventes et de là il y a eu un
véritable boom au niveau international
et voilà un bienment
piauh désormais nous avons plus de 1000
demandes pour acheter des maisons à 1 €
des demandes de France du Brésil d'Inde
du Japon plus de 80 maisons à un euro
ont déjà été vendu et en échange les
acheteurs s'engagent à les restaurer
dans les trois ans avec des artisans
locaux un moyen de doper l'économie du
village sans aucun investissement public
mais outre le prix ce qui séduit les
acheteurs c'est la sécurité de leur
investissement Ganji est souvent cité
comme une ville bien gérée de quoi
éviter toute infiltration mafieuse
est connue à l'étranger à cause bien sûr
de la mafia mais vous savez le fait que
nous soyons dans les terres loin des
grandes voies de communication nous a
sans doute préservé de ce fléau
Gandji est loin d'être un cas isolé des
biens publics inoccupés l'Italie n'en
manque pas et pas seulement en Sicile
nous voici maintenant à Rome cet hôpital
pourtant situé dans l'une des rues les
plus commerçantes de la capitale est à
l'abandon avec environ 46000 terrains et
bâtiments comme celui-ci l'État est à la
tête d'un patrimoine cessible estimé
après de 60 milliards d'euros et celles
qui centralise tout c'est la jansia DEL
démagno qui dépend directement du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
sa mission gérer tout ce patrimoine et
le vendre si nécessaire
on a des villas des châteaux des phares
des villages des couvents on a le phare
de brucolio à langousta et une des plus
belles pièces de notre catalogue à le
voilà c'est celle-ci le superbe hôtel
des termes de San Pellegrino
l'objectif principal dans la
valorisation de ses biens ce n'est
absolument pas de remplir les caisses à
tout prix mais de réduire les coûts
car pour la collectivité tout s'est bien
inoccupé coûte très cher
alors bientôt un colisée ou un panthéon
privatisé impossible le ministère des
biens culturels veille au grain grâce à
un solide arsenal législatif
le scénario paraît bien rodé pourtant
parmi les biens d'exception sur le
marché certains ne trouvent pas preneurs
dans l'un des quartiers les plus chics
de Rome cet ancien hôtel des monnaies
est inoccupé depuis une dizaine d'années
Thomas soditano économiste spécialiste
du patrimoine public à son explication
le privé ne peut pas tout l'État doit
aussi mettre la main à la poche pour
certaines infrastructures
pourrait devenir un hôtel de luxe un
centre de conférence ou encore un centre
commercial
il faudrait alors un système de parking
pour que les voitures puissent se garer
sous la place valoriser son patrimoine
culturel quitte à le vendre pour
développer un tourisme de luxe voilà le
pari de l'Italie une manière de remplir
les caisses de l'étape parfois taxé de
grandes braderies par ces détracteurs
et pour évoquer cette question c'est
Younous Omar j que je reçois bonjour
vous êtes député européen membres de la
Gauche Unitaire européenne et vous êtes
vice-président de la commission du
développement régional quand vous voyez
la manière dont on privatise le
patrimoine italien est-ce que c'est une
braderie selon vous ou c'est juste moyen
de remplir les caisses et de
rationaliser le patrimoine de l'État
c'est surtout consternant et ça va bien
au-delà bon s'agissant de cette commune
qui est une petite commune
elle avait énormément de difficultés à
restaurer son patrimoine et en
particulier le centre urbain et le maire
a eu cette idée un peu curieuse de
vendre pour 1 euro pour un euro les
maisons du centre contre réhabilitation
contre réhabilitation et rénovation
pourquoi tout simplement parce que les
communes des collectivités territoriales
les régions européennes souvent sont
dans une situation
la matière catastrophique mais les
communes en particulier sont exanges et
non plus les moyens de faire face à ces
nécessités et elles font appel
évidemment soit au privé soit à ses
appels de fonds pour pouvoir assumer
effectivement qu'il y a beaucoup
d'étrangers qui viennent investir
la bien montré ça pose une série de
problèmes sur l'évasion d'une certaine
manière on parle de l'évasion fiscale
mais là on est confronté à une évasion
de notre patrimoine culturel ça vous
choque et de notre patrimoine historique
c'est évidemment en capacité de le
prendre en charge c'est évidemment
profondément choquant parce qu'il y a
des biens
qui soient culturels ou même des
paysages vous savez qu'en Autriche par
exemple on a été jusqu'à vendre une
montagne bon jusqu'où s'arrêtera ton et
bien ce sont des biens qui font partie
de mon la vue du patrimoine commun et
qu'il faut laisser à l'abri il faudrait
que ce soit incessible selon vous
invendable de biens oui
on parle de l'Italie les trésors de la
Renaissance
seront-ils demain vendus vous parlez du
Colisée
j'ai une passion pour Florence je pense
à ce trésor bon qui est à Florence
est-ce qu'on franchira le pas jusqu'à
vendre demain les œuvres de Michel-Ange
mais alors que à partir du moment où on
a plus les moyens de nos de notre
patrimoine et de est-ce que il y a
vraiment un problème à aller chercher
l'argent là où il est c'est-à-dire chez
les étrangers et notamment on a vu des
Singapouriens dans ce reportage et cela
conforte l'idée évidemment que les
étrangers s'accaparent du patrimoine
national c'est une forme de
protectionnisme là que vous mettez en
avant en France par exemple ou de très
beaux bâtiments de très beaux hôtels
sont rachetés par des qatari etc ou
alors par des chinois pour d'autres
biens et dans la population on dit notre
patrimoine aujourd'hui appartient aux
étrangers et ça pose encore d'autres
problèmes mais il y a d'autres solutions
bon qui sont beaucoup plus douces le
mécénat c'est grands groupes privés qui
font des milliards de bénéfices ils
peuvent participer à ses missions par le
mécénat dans les cahiers des charges que
les collectivités ou les étapes passent
avec un certain nombre d'entreprises on
peut même dans certains nombre
d'obligations sur ce plan mais le choix
manifestement a été fait de tout
marchandiser
et de faire tomber aujourd'hui dans
l'escarcelle du privé ce qui appartient
à tous alors justement le ministère de
la Culture que nous avons rencontré dans
le cadre de ce reportage avait une
question directe à vous poser je
souhaiterais qu'on l'écoute
que doit-on faire pour convaincre les
autres gouvernements nationaux
qu'investir dans la culture le tourisme
et le patrimoine et le meilleur moyen de
surmonter la crise de créer des emplois
et du développement
alors est-ce que la culture et le
tourisme peuvent être un moyen de
relancer l'économie atome de l'Union
européenne oui et d'abord on voit bien
qu'en période de crise c'est toujours la
culture qui en est la première victime
dans les budgets aussi bien au niveau
national que parfois même à d'autres
niveaux c'est toujours la culture
monsieur qui accuse justement or est-ce
qu'on a les moyens de s'offrir une
politique culturelle digne de ce nom au
vu des problématiques qui se posent par
ailleurs or la culture et le tourisme
peuvent contribuer à participer à la
relance à la relance économique par
l'investissement et à la création
d'emplois donc il faut maintenir une
politique culturelle ambitieuse dans
l'ensemble des pays européens mais
surtout il faut une véritable politique
culturelle européenne je reviens de
plénière justement j'allais vous poser
la question quand vous entendez
Jean-Claude Juncker qui annonce 300
milliards d'investissements global
est-ce que vous appelez de vos vœux qui
est dans ces 300 milliards quelques
lignes pour la politique je reviens de
plénière et il y a des députés peut-être
même de mon groupe d'ailleurs qui ont
déposé un amendement demandant la
suppression c'est pas très important
mais c'est symbolique demandant la
suppression du musée sur l'histoire de
l'Europe c'est le budget de 2015 il faut
faire des économies et on va tout de
suite aller chercher sur la culture
évidemment sur ces 300 milliards que
Jean-Claude Juncker a annoncé vous et
votre groupe n'avez pas voté
l'investiture de cette nouvelle
commission
donc est-ce que malgré tout vous
demandez dans une ligne de ces 300
milliards parce que il y ait un petit
peu de politique culturelle ou pas je me
suis absolu sur la commission Junker
s'agissant des 300 milliards j'étais à
1000 ans pour le Conseil des ministres
et j'ai posé la question au 28
ministres une question simple
où sont ces 300 milliards est-ce que
c'est de l'argent frais puisque nous
avons besoin de 300 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour attendre les effets
escomptés sur l'investissement et pour
la croissance pour le moment
ils ne sont nulle part Jean-Claude
Juncker ce matin annoncé
ces 300 milliards pour Noël et bien
c'est un beau cadeau mais pour le moment
le paquet
cadeau qui est vide pour le moment et
j'ai bien peur vous êtes abstenus j'ai
bien peur que ce ne soit que de
l'affichage je n'ai pas voté contre la
commission Junker je me suis absolu
considérant que c'est un pari je crois
qu'il faut aussi noter chez Jean-Claude
Junker quelques ruptures positives par
rapport à Barroso il faut qu'il soit
soutenu dans ses volontés d'aller un peu
plus en avant pour une Europe sociale et
ceux qui ont voté pour lui ou qui se
sont absolus seront là pour lui rappeler
ses engagements et ben écoutez on vous
invitera pour que vous rappeliez à
Jean-Claude un cœur ses engagements
merci beaucoup Iono
nous c'est la fin de cette émission
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine à
Bruxelles avec Katia guilder bonne suite
de programme sur les chaînes
parlementaires Ciao